and we saw
the cdc officials and nih and fauci
specifically attack me along with
elizabeth warren and rachel maddow night
after night but we also you know
recognized too that people in my state
weren't necessarily supportive either
you know there was times where it was
hard to find
a lot of encouragement even from people
who lived here that my lieutenant
governor tells the story that he would
get phone calls from even our best
supporters that would say hey you got to
get the governor in line
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the governor of the great state of south
dakota as well as author of the new book
not my first rodeo lessons from the
heartland governor christie gnome
welcome to the reuben report oh thank
you i'm thrilled to be here i appreciate
the invitation i am glad to finally chat
with you because i always tell people i
have a short list it's a very short list
i have it in front of me right now of
sane politicians
and you're on the list so
congratulations oh it's a good day
that's wonderful to hear
i'll put it on my resume there you go so
i want to dive into a bit about the book
and a bit about hot topics of the day
and a bunch more but in the book you
kind of go into your your history your
childhood and really how it sets up a
lot of your political beliefs so i
thought we could just start there maybe
for some of the people that don't know
too much about your your bio
well i think a lot of people would look
at me writing a book and think it's a
book about politics and it's really not
it's about my life lived so far
i most people heard my name for the
first time during covid and
didn't know anything about me maybe made
some assumptions based on the decisions
that i was making and i think it's
important that for people to understand
the decisions that i make they have to
know a little bit about me the way i
grew up i think was pretty special
there's a lot of life lessons i learned
from my family
my faith and in the ranch and i think it
is
some of those lessons that that helped
south dakota and myself do what we've
done the last couple of years that i
believe really
is uh an inspiration to the rest of the
country here in south dakota we have
embraced freedom
unlike any other state and it really is
benefiting not only the people who live
here but also our economy and our way of
life yeah it really has i mentioned to
you right before we started that
although i didn't quite get to meet you
we were separated by about five feet we
walked past each other at freedom fest
after you had spoke and then i went to
mount rushmore that very day it was the
first time i'd ever been there and just
the spirit of america and it was it was
still the middle of covet i suppose but
just the amount of people that were out
in
street festivals out and about happy you
know somewhere in mass some not making
decisions for themselves it was so
refreshing uh but can you go into a
little bit of that growing up in the
heartland and what some of that family
stuff that you learned uh maybe how that
translated into some of the politics
that we'll get to
well my dad was a cowboy oh and he was
tough all we did was work and if we
didn't work we were hunting in fact even
our family vacations were
loading the horses up in the trailer and
headed to the mountains for two weeks on
elk hunts or big game hunts and so it
was a very different childhood maybe
than typically what american kids get
the chance to experience today
but i also learned a lot from having a
dad that gave us
incredibly hard things to do you know
many times growing up i thought is this
guy trying to kill us because he just
gave us
challenges but i realized that by doing
that he made us into problem solvers and
when we did something that was very hard
that we didn't think we could accomplish
it gave us confidence to tackle the next
biggest thing so a lot of the stories in
the book are working with cattle or
hunting trips or lessons learned from my
mom and dad
but they also address kind of a way of
life that's kind of about the american
west that i think people are still very
curious about today and our politics
were not talked about in our home we
weren't a political family at all
instead they were lived they were in
how we lived our way of life in fact i
remember i was telling somebody the
other day my when south dakota passed
the law that required seat belts i
remember being young and watching my dad
uh take a jackknife and then cut the
seat belts out of his brand new pickup
and i asked him why he was doing that
and he told me because the state had
just passed a law that mandated it and
it wasn't that he was against wearing
his seatbelt he wore his seat belt it
was that he was against the government
telling him he had to
and and it was lessons like that that
really
made me think about government its role
in your life uh in a very different way
that i think a lot of people get the
chance to today when they just turn on
the news and get their opinions that way
so from a family that wasn't necessarily
talking politics but sort of living it
as you describe what possessed you to
get into this crazy game known as
politics of today
you know i would say it was a tragedy we
lost my dad in an accident on our farm
when he was 49 years old
i was 22 at the time i was married i'd
gotten married when i was 20 but i was
still going to college and it just
turned our whole lives upside down he he
was kind of superman you know he
we had a very large farming operation
and ranching operation probably one of
the largest in the state
many other businesses
and when he was gone
we had no idea how we were going to keep
the operation going in fact i became the
general manager
at 22 and
you know had a lot of people working for
us relying on us trying not to lose our
family business when i got a letter in
the mail from the irs that said we owed
death taxes
and i hadn't heard of death taxes before
that but all of a sudden because we had
this tragedy
and our whole lives have been turned
upside down now we owed hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of dollars to the
federal government in taxes and it made
me angry
so that's what got me involved is i just
started showing up at meetings i was
passionate about tax reform
uh at that time our senator from south
dakota was tom daschle he was the u.s
senate majority leader at the time
and i showed up at all of his meetings
and started talking policy and
remembering that my dad always told us
growing up christy we don't complain
about things we fix them
and but it took me 10 years to pay off
those taxes so during that time i was
pretty passionate about getting rid of
that unfair
tax that hits a family at a time of
tragedy
yeah so
as you mentioned earlier
what sort of put you on the map
nationally was the covid situation and
that you didn't go for lockdowns and you
fought the system and all that as you
may know i lived in california for
mostakovid i now live in the free state
of florida and as i keep telling my
audience it's like living in another
country i genuinely feel that i left one
country and moved to another which is
the beauty of federalism can you talk a
little bit about those first couple
weeks of covid the pressure you were
under and how you made your decisions uh
you know who you were taking advice from
et cetera
well i would say it was it was uh
immense pressure you know
we were told right away before the virus
even came to the state of south dakota
that i would have over 300 000 people
die
from this virus that was coming and that
i needed to do something about it to
slow down the spread and protect people
who were vulnerable
so i think i did what every other
governor did talk to a lot of health
officials and experts studied the virus
learned from other states when they were
first affected what i did differently
was i believe i spent a lot more time
with my general counsel
a lot of time with constitutional
attorneys i really wanted to understand
what my job was as governor
and what my job wasn't what authority i
did not have because i just believe that
when leaders overstep their authority
especially in a time of crisis like that
that that's really when we break the
foundation of this country i knew for a
fact
i did not want to be the governor who
did that so south dakota did end up
being the only state that never once
closed a business or mandated anything
while other states were closing beaches
and closing businesses and stopping
big meetings and gatherings south dakota
did something very different in fact i
was
shocked and surprised how people were
rolling over and giving up their
freedoms in many states
so we went on the offense you know we
ran a national advertising campaign
right away in 2020 inviting everybody to
come to south dakota well while your
state's locked down come and spend time
here be free
and
hundreds of thousands of people came
they came and spent some time here and
then many of those people went back home
packed up their families and moved here
so it's been an incredible testimony to
to what happened in that in that
pandemic i think the very day that crazy
video of the cop chasing down the guy in
malibu on the beach you remember that
thank you absolutely i remember that day
and i lived not too far from there i i
saw you on fox saying you know we're
going to stay open and really thinking
man this this is what's happening in
america right now it's just it's just
many many different countries so were
you talking to other governors also i
mean i you know some like desantis
obviously we're doing something a lot
closer to what you were doing but you
know gavin newsom who was my governor in
cali was obviously doing something very
different ho chill up and or at the time
it was cuomo in new york but now ho
chill has continued a lot of that stuff
well we talked a lot not so much with
democrat governors you know there would
be different conference calls through
the national governors association that
were hosted and facilitated but i
learned quickly
that those weren't beneficial they we
weren't getting any new information from
them and that we needed to prioritize
where my time was being spent we did
have conference calls with governors who
were keeping their states open
and
you know we we just organized that
ourselves we were all republicans but we
had weekly sometimes bi-weekly phone
calls with learning what we could learn
about the virus from each other it was a
governor's only call
also learning what other people were
doing what measures they were taking
what they were recommending
but we also made sure that that call
only stayed
for the governors that kept their states
open and every week
less and less governors were on the call
it was kind of interesting how
candid we were you know so we'd get on
that call and and somebody would say hey
guys
i gotta let you know this is my last
phone call i'll be on my entire team is
telling me that i've got to shut down
businesses because the spread's getting
too bad so i'm just here to let you know
that tomorrow i'm putting out a press
release and closing the state and and i
won't be on these calls anymore and
and we would say okay and then there was
less and less so there was times where
it got down to 12 of us and then a week
later there was eight of us and
then there was less of us and down until
i was the only one left so it was it was
interesting
times but i also many of those
republican governors maybe didn't have
the situation that i had either you know
i
had an incredible executive team that
when i made a decision they said okay
that's the decision and they did it and
and
my hospital administrators were very
involved we talked many times a day when
we made decisions it was based on
science it was not based on what was
playing on the news
that was very helpful they were common
sense reasonable people who want to take
care of each other and the state
partnered with them in ways that i don't
think happened in other states our
national guard
and other entities were heavily involved
in helping them
build up capacity and staffing
very innovative in how we approached it
that i think allowed us to do what we
did
what kind of pushback were you getting
behind the scenes even if you had
support in the state i would imagine you
know there had to be some calls from
maybe people at the nih or cdc or just
whatever legal people whatever just
saying hey you can stay open but we're
coming for you basically one way or
another yeah i think we got push i mean
we got pushback from every angle
everywhere and and even the national
media made it worse because they just
specifically targeted me there would be
hot spots all over the country but all
they talked about at night
on the news was south dakota and our
meat packing plant or the sturgis
motorcycle bike rally or this
irresponsible event we were going to be
hosting at mount rushmore you know they
specifically went after
me in a way that we'd never seen before
and we saw
the cdc officials and nih and fauci
specifically attack me along with
elizabeth warren and rachel maddow night
after night but we also you know
recognized too that people in my state
weren't necessarily supportive either
you know there was times where it was
hard to find
a lot of encouragement even from people
who lived here that my lieutenant
governor tells the story that he would
get phone calls from
even our best supporters that would say
hey you got to get the governor in line
this is going to
this is going to kill her politically
and she's got to start falling in line
with these other governors and you know
to his credit and to my executive team
they they said she is firm in her
decision um she has already decided this
she doesn't have the authority therefore
she's not going to overstep and
and we are in in line with her and and
that that made it
a wonderful thing for me because many
times those contentious phone calls they
were taking they didn't necessarily
always tell me about they knew where i
was
and we were a team taking care of people
together did you ever have a moment
where you almost cracked and and said
okay i'm gonna have to do some lockdowns
or some version of something like did
the pressure ever get to that point
where you got close
you know i don't think i ever got close
although it was hard there were days
that that i would say
you know i hung up a phone or got off a
zoom call where i thought
man i don't know
how much longer i can do this you know
my family was pretty remarkable i have a
son that's now 20 but he was
18 at the time that sat by my desk for
18 hours a day and just sat there um so
and i think it was to remind me that
somebody was going to love me no matter
what you know and then when i got off a
a phone call that was contentious
because i spent a lot of time managing
other leaders i spent a lot of time
you know having conference calls with
mayors
with city council members with county
commissioners you know once i made a
decision i spent a ton of time
communicating with them about why i was
making the decision i was making but
when i would hang up with a phone call
that obviously was contentious or
stressful you know in a way he would say
mom
let's go shoot baskets for five minutes
and
and so we'd go outside and shoot baskets
for five or ten minutes and
and you know get a little bit of a break
and then i'd go back to work or let's go
play cards for it he was good at giving
me some perspective and i think my whole
family
you know being here with me made a world
of difference i mean they
they really supported me and reminded me
that that here in south dakota just
because the national
leaders are making very different
decisions
didn't mean that that was going to be
south dakota's path what i appreciated
the most
was that president trump let me do my
job
is if joe biden had been in the white
house during this time i know for a fact
he would have come after us and really
been punitive against the state of south
dakota and done all he could to destroy
me
and president trump let me do my job as
governor and for that i'll always be
grateful are you shocked or were you
shocked that during all of this the same
people who were calling trump hitler
every day and all the horrible things
that they would call him that he was
basically kicking the power back to the
states so taking less power for himself
less power to the federal government and
they were angry at him for that the guy
who they said was the worst of the worst
that's right yeah that's exactly it and
what i found was
uh even at the local level many mayors
and city council members they wanted me
to make the tough decision so they
didn't have to
um and and there was so that's the exact
opposite of president trump it wasn't
that he wasn't willing to make tough
decisions he was very clear on what his
recommendations were
but then he let us do our job and and
that's what i kept saying to the mayors
and the city councilmen is listen this
is not my authority to do this
um you can make different decisions but
i want you to know that i'm going to be
here holding you accountable as well you
shut down your city
and we have 100 cases there and then two
weeks from now you open it back up
because people can't take it anymore and
you have 500 cases i'm going to blow you
up i'm going to call a press conference
and say you locked people in their homes
and only let them out when it got worse
so i said i consistently was reminding
people why don't you shut off your tv
let's talk over the data and the facts
of this virus and then just i'll call
you in the morning i know you're nervous
i know you're
anxious i know you're uncertain so let's
just take a night and i'll call you in
the morning and let's talk again and
then a lot of
what happened during the pandemic was
that kind of communication that i think
was to our benefit
i would be remiss if i didn't back up
for a second and ask you about your
basketball skills do you have skills out
there they needed some tuning up so i
they were not horrible in high school i
did play basketball but uh yeah that six
five son of mine can can school me every
day on the basketball court so speaking
of sports actually we've got a good
transition there one of the other things
you've been leading on is actually
keeping boys and girls in separate
sports leagues and it's okay and it's
not based in bigotry or anything else
are you shocked that this even got to
your desk and and that you had to kind
of lead on this thing because everyone's
talking about it now but you were really
doing this it's almost two years ago at
this point we know i started this fight
probably five years ago you know people
don't remember this but when i was in
congress the federal government came
down
and told south dakota that we could no
longer have girls events and boys events
in the sport of rodeo which you know a
lot of people don't pay attention to
rodeo so it never made national news but
to south dakota that was a really big
deal it's our state sport
and they told us that it was too
discriminatory to have a girls event and
a boys event and that we had to
eliminate all gender references in that
sport statewide
and i fought them i
fought them alone
nobody really cared at that time about
this issue or they thought it was too
politically dangerous to really wade
into
but ended up winning that argument at
that time so this is something i'd been
a part of fighting for many many years
when it came to protecting girls sports
now that it's a national issue
i wanted the strongest bill in the
nation in the state of south dakota
because i know that
this is a basic fairness issue this is
about only girls playing in girls sports
so they have an opportunity to be
successful and to succeed maybe win a
scholarship go on and play
professionally if that opportunity
presents itself and that biological
males should not be playing in their
same events but
it's interesting to me to watch the kind
of attacks that have come
just because
you know this it serves a political
agenda for us in south dakota i know
that as soon as we passed a bill that
was going to be put into statute it
would be challenged in court and i did
not want to pass a flawed bill that made
us vulnerable to having it overturned
and setting up incredible precedent that
would leave us in a situation where i
wouldn't be able to enforce
this rule in our state and be in a
situation where we would always have to
have boys playing in girls sports so i'm
proud of the bill we passed it was
something i authored and the legislature
supported and now south dakota is the
state that that has the most
strongest and
uh court
challenged
you know will withstand a court
challenged the best in the nation
are there court cases about that right
now i mean just in the last couple weeks
we one of the things we've covered here
is that
the federal government wants to come
after states that pass bills like this
and potentially withhold school lunches
from kids in states that do things like
this so you're going to punish the kids
who have nothing to do with this i mean
right it's typical of everything going
on with this government but
yeah you're exactly right you know there
there isn't court challenges right now
although if we had done flawed bills
then they would have used that
opportunity to undermine them and set up
precedent but yes what's interesting is
the biden administration has come to
south dakota and said listen you either
let boys play in girls sports or we're
going to withhold school lunches which i
think is the craziest thing i've ever
heard i mean not only does this
administration
not care about solving our baby formula
issue but then they go and threaten to
take away food from children to create
an unfair situation for women so they're
going after women children and babies
and it's hard for me to believe that
anybody supports the democrat party
anymore after what joe biden is doing uh
it's it's amazing to me that to
have this kind of a
left extremist agenda that they would go
after women and children and literally
threaten taking away taking away food in
their schools
you mentioned tom daschle before who was
a a democrat so did i mean when you had
a guy like him who you obviously had
some disagreements with when you were
younger of course but he i don't think
he was like a crazy crazy lefty the way
they seem to be now do you have a sense
of how that shifted maybe how it shifted
in your state and i think everyone can
sort of see it at a national level at
this point
i would say that at the time he was
serving you know he would have been a
more moderate democrat
and south dakota elects a lot of
democrats to federal level people tend
to think of south dakota as a very
conservative state and that's just not
necessarily true when we elect officials
to washington d.c
you know
tom was what people probably would call
more of a
blue dog democrat you know maybe
cooperated with republicans a little bit
more
it did catch up with him some of his
votes and his way of life but when i ran
for congress i ran against a democrat
that had a very high approval rating in
the state of south dakota it was a very
tough race one of the top five races in
the nation at that time
and even my last race
running for governor here in south
dakota i only won that race by three
points and
it was to a democrat who embraced bernie
sanders
policies so you know i think a lot of
people see the conservative things that
are going on in south dakota and think
wow well that's easy to do in a red
state like that well we're we're getting
more and more red all the time but but
there's been a lot of democrats that
have been elected in south dakota and
they got elected by being more populist
rather than
the extreme far left that we see in the
country right now do you see a parallel
between south dakota and florida in that
you know desantis who's now crushing it
here and and you guys have many of the
same policies um you know he only won by
30 000 votes and it turns out that the
guy he beat
he became a meth addict or
or maybe maybe was a math addict at the
time i don't know about that but the
point being that you guys both won
pretty close races and the country could
look very very different if you know
south dakota and florida had turned blue
i mean it radically would yeah i think i
think so you know ron and i got elected
to congress the same year we served for
eight years together in the house and
both ran for governor at the same time
we both have very different states but
we do have higher than average elderly
populations so that all got taken into
account when we were making our
decisions as well recognizing we had a
higher ratio ratio of our population
that would be vulnerable
but at the end of the day i think we
made the decisions that were best for
our people we still made very different
decisions you know he had some closures
at different times different mandates
but but i do think that every governor
it's it's easy for people to pass
judgment
on on them from the outside two or three
years later i will say that for every
single governor it was a it was a
difficult time every decision was hard
so you've been ahead on a couple things
we talked about covet obviously and and
some of the gender stuff one of the
other things you've been talking about
is food security
and for my audience obviously doesn't
watch much mainstream media but they are
paying attention to what's going on
online i mean every day there are new
headlines about uh you know meat uh
producing fields and all of these things
that are that are on fire
factories seem to be burning up that our
our food security really seems to be
threatened right now there was this
weird thing in kansas with 2000 cattle
dying out of nowhere supposedly from
heat what what is going on here
well i've been talking about food
security as a national security issue
for 15 years i served on a committee
in the state of course i am a farmer and
a rancher that's how i've made my living
my entire life until i got involved in
government and politics but
beyond that i served on a committee that
oversaw the federal farm programs in the
state but i recognized that america has
always embraced a food policy of having
it be diversified
in in the country so that one person
doesn't control our food supply that
many different farmers and small
businesses do and processors but that
also
we have had a cheap food policy we
wanted every single family in this
country to be able to afford to put food
on the table for their families
and i've been drawing attention for 15
years to the fact that we are losing
both of those
battles that we have we have more and
more foreign countries buying up our
processing systems they're buying up our
fertilizer companies our chemical
companies our processing facilities
not only is china manipulating their
currency but stealing our ip building up
their military they're also buying our
land
they own a lot of our food supply chain
system and when another country controls
our food
that is when they control us so they're
not dummies
and i think that these higher costs are
already forcing families to make
decisions on what they can buy and what
they can feed their families and when we
get another country that truly does
control the entire supply system that's
when america gets scary you know i think
a virus was
was a situation where the entire country
was nervous
i would say wait till there's no food on
the grocery store shelves and that's
really when you start to see our way of
life being threatened so so what do we
do what do we do i mean biden said it
himself a couple months ago food
shortages you know they i think was that
the economist or one of the big major
magazines the food shortages are coming
world economic forum worrying about uh
talking about it bill gates is now the
largest farm land owner in the united
states i mean what what do you do as a
governor of a state what do you do well
first of all i have to be honest and
talk about it uh this this
administration's not talking about
solving the problem
uh and in fact they're facilitating
foreign countries coming in and buying
up our systems in our land uh so the
administration being honest and
recognizing it as is a real challenge
and solving it would be important
cutting regulations to allow more of our
american businesses to to buy back these
facilities to be in production
agriculture to grow our own food is
important right now they're attacking
our farmers and ranchers and their
penalizing them and putting heavy
regulations on them that don't allow
people to work on their land don't allow
their children to participate in the
business at all and in south dakota here
we've been aggressive in cutting back
regulations we've also been aggressive
and building our own processing plants
i've given millions and millions of
grants to people who want to build a
meat packing plant or expand the
facility that would put value-added food
on the table for families here so that
we control our own destiny and that many
many of these producers can control
their own supply chain to get it right
to the customer we're bypassing a lot of
these big corporations that that own the
systems that are stealing the profits
away from those that are actually
growing the food and making sure we're
putting that control back in the hands
of the consumer who needs to put that
food on the table
what do you make of this administration
when it comes to everything we've talked
about here do you believe that it's
ineptitude or do you think that this is
intentional everything that's happening
right now
well
you know there's it's there's been a a
year and a half here where i thought you
know this guy's like the george costanza
of government like his
every instinct he makes is just wrong if
he would wake up in the morning yes he
should it just so but i i believe now
that meant much of this is intentional
that there's no way that somebody is
making decisions like this that truly
loves america
he is crippling our country
and and you can't possibly be making
these kinds of decisions
um and have it just be a mistake so
there's an agenda here to control people
and uh it's been in place for a period
of time i'm not going to say it's coming
straight out of joe biden i think most
of the time he's not even aware of
what's going on necessarily but he's
being controlled
by by people who definitely do not want
a republic to continue in this country i
would have never thought three or four
years ago that we'd have the
conversations we're having today that a
country could change as fast as america
has
i knew when i served in congress that i
served with members that were socialists
that embraced the policies and their
ways of life but they never would have
admitted it publicly and now look what's
happened they're openly holding press
conferences and embracing socialist and
marxist
platforms and programs for the united
states of america so
if people who think that well you know
this is just another
episode like we saw in the 70s you know
yes we've been through challenging times
in the past some of them
traits are familiar some of the riots
and the violence you know we we can
remember in our history where we've seen
that before but this is different
because they are trying to remake
america and they're getting more
traction than they've ever gotten before
speaking of that did you guys have any
of the the crazy riots that we saw
everywhere i mean it was usually in in
blue states and in blue cities but did
you have any of that during the summer
of tolerance or violence depending on
which way you look at well we had one
event that was planned a protest in our
largest city that was planned and i
pre-staged my national guard
to several different cities that night
and also my law enforcement officers and
then just told those i set up emergency
operations centers in each of these
cities too and coordinated everything
with the local law enforcement and
mayors in those towns but that evening
in sioux falls which is our largest city
i said as soon as we they throw the
first water bottle we're going in
and and so we did this crowd of
thousands of people
you know built throughout the night
moved throughout the city and when it
started to get violent we immediately
moved in and shut it down and said we
weren't going to stand peaceful protests
we will allow that's our constitutional
right but as soon as one thing happens
that turns it into something very
different south dakota wouldn't stand
for it so it was remarkable what
happened
in south dakota because we didn't have
issues after after that period people
knew where we stood they knew we
protected law and order and even it was
kind of amazing because they had spread
out so far be in the city
uh you know having enough help was
incredibly important we saw citizens
come out
um
they were armed to help protect the
downtown streets we had motorcycle
groups come out and say we've got these
blocks the national guard can move down
to an area where there's more of a
threat and it was amazing to watch
people partner with our law enforcement
and with our guard members to keep
everybody safe
are you telling me that people who
law-abidingly own weapons for their own
self-defense sometimes do good things
because that's not the meme out there
yeah no they did incredible things
during that period of time it was
remarkable to see even when president
trump
came to mount rushmore we had protests
throughout the black hills because at
that time
across the country people were tearing
down monuments they were tearing down
statutes and here
south dakota dared to have a celebration
in honor of the leaders on mount
rushmore and president trump in our
freedom
and
you know organized protesters those
seeking violence showed up and tried to
destroy the monument tried to create
problems that evening for the president
and we had
hundreds and hundreds of civilians
and again a lot of these motorcycle
groups came in rolled into these small
towns and kept law order for us so that
we could have a peaceful event where we
really did get to focus on america i'm
sure you hear it probably every day of
your life but i had never been to mount
rushmore until you know a year or two
ago when i went i mean it is truly i've
been to every monument and every you
know important place in the united
states it is the most breathtaking
absolutely incredible it's it's
mind-boggling that this thing was even
made it really is
it is it it at the time it was made the
incredible efforts that had to be done
and uh you know what's interesting is
just the need to protect it at this day
and age too you know we have
we have still security up there making
sure it's protected from protesters who
try to dump red paint down the faces or
try to
set off explosives to send a message
that's anti-american so
so it is a special treasure for us you
know people always get south and north
dakota confused and i'm constantly
saying to them north dakota got all the
oil
south dakota got mount rushmore and and
we're okay with that
so let's just go through a couple of the
other uh hot button issues that you've
been talking about obviously as we're
taping this we're holding it for a
couple days so it is possible that this
roe v wade decision because the supreme
court is making all these decisions this
week that are being released it may have
been already announced but it sounds
like roe v wade is going to be reversed
uh according to this leaked briefing
that we heard about a couple months ago
obviously you're pro-life what do you
think the policy of south dakota is
going to be going forward will there be
any
room on that related to some of these uh
extreme cases etc etc
well right now in south dakota there are
no abortions being performed in our
state which is something i'm very proud
of you know i i ran for governor saying
i wanted to be the most pro-life
governor in the country
every action we've taken every bill
we've we've passed has been protecting
every single
innocent life and you know this decision
will be
monumental in the country south dakota
has a trigger law in place so as soon as
that decision comes forward abortions
will be illegal in the state of south
dakota except for in protection of the
life of the mother
i have already told my legislature that
we may have a need for a special session
to see what we can do to really partner
and help care for mothers that are in a
situation where they have a baby that
may need health care that found
themselves in a crisis situation or
facilitate better adoption
situations to connect people better make
sure that these children have the
opportunity to grow up in a home
where they're loved and cherished and
can be successful for many years to come
so
with that trigger laws important but
there also may be a need to make sure
that we clarify that the mothers aren't
the ones that we that should be punished
in this situation that it is those who
perform the abortions and knowingly
break the law doing it that need to be
punished are you getting any traction on
some of those programs whether it's
adoption or figuring out other ways to
help the kids because to me that's where
conservatives i think can really make
gra make some headway with some of the
disaffected liberals there's so many
disaffected liberals right now
so many people that don't want eight
month abortion seven month abortions all
the crazy stuff coming out of california
but they view something like oh no
abortions and now no government help as
just too far yeah and i agree we don't
spend nearly enough time talking about
taking care of mothers in crisis we just
don't and we should because that's
really the challenge that most of these
young women
are in and they're scared of is you know
it's one thing to tell me i gotta have
this baby how do i get to a doctor how
do i feed it when it's here how do i
care for it and then what so when i
became governor i made it a one of my
major issues is to facilitate adoption
and
foster care services
we've dramatically increased the amount
of foster families in our in our state i
made it a priority to say that in every
major speech i would talk about foster
care and adoption and we've seen that
be facilitated in many many
ways and grow throughout the state and
encourage these foster families to keep
these children in their homes and to
adopt them so we also as a state passed
a law that would help pay for the home
studies that are required of adoptions
and to help with a financial burden of
bringing a child into their home
permanently so i have in my family my
brothers adopted three children my
sister's adopted
a son you know we're very familiar with
adoption i grew up with a foster brother
and so it's something i'm passionate
about and i think it's an opportunity
for all of us to start recognizing that
we're in these positions to take care of
people to serve people and that a lot of
this a pro-life discussion is about
making sure that those mothers have an
opportunity to have a quality of life
and to make sure their babies are in a
safe home
so let's just do one more hot button
issue before i let you go we we sort of
talked about guns for just a second a
moment ago but you're obviously a big
defender of the second amendment we have
all of this legislation trying to be
passed or half passed right now in wake
of the uvalde shooting
i guess
well broadly what is your position on
the second amendment i guess that's
obvious uh but but what do you think is
going to happen as the federal
government seems to want to encroach
more on the states related to gun rights
well the very first bill that i signed
as governor was constitutional carry it
had been vetoed by the previous governor
a couple of times and it was i was
passionate about this constitutional
right so we had a big ceremony in the
rotunda and celebrated this bill finally
becoming law in the state of south
dakota and since then we've passed quite
a few different bills and
and pieces of legislation that make it
clear that if you want to exercise your
second amendment rights in south dakota
please do in fact this last year
i removed all fees for concealed carry
permits any permit that would be
required and said the state of south
dakota would even pay for a person's
federal background check
so there would be zero cost to
exercising your second amendment rights
here i think it's important we lead by
example and the discussion on violence
and tragedies that happens in this
country
is
is heartbreaking to see i think what we
need to remember though is that this is
a constitutionally protected right and
it is a right that guarantees all the
other
uh bill of rights um it is the the the
militia
the citizen militia that that fought for
our freedom in this country during the
revolutionary war did so with their own
weapons with the weapons that they had
to feed their families
to hunt deer and squirrel they used
those to fight for their freedom and
they wanted it enshrined
in our bill of rights that we always
have the opportunity for each individual
in this country to be able to defend
themselves with their own weapons and it
wasn't from
other people in their community it was
from a corrupt government and
and that is what i think is imperative
is that we remain focused on the reason
that the second amendment exists talk
about the history and ensure that we
keep that protection in place
it is unclear to me whether the
government is inept corrupt or malicious
at this point but i would say all of the
above
it might be all three and of course
governor i cannot let you go without
asking the most important question you
knew it was coming
are you running in 2024 oh come on no
evasive answers what i had for breakfast
this morning so
you know i i have no plans to i'm
running for re-election this year
and uh i have to get asked the people of
south dakota if they'll trust me to to
work with them for the next four years
i'm hopeful they will and i also think
2024
there'll be a lot of people running for
president at that point i think anybody
who wants to run for president that gets
up every single day
and and that's their number one desire
maybe that's not the kind of president
that we want we it might be time for
this country to have someone who steps
up because they feel a duty to protect
this country and our freedom
amen
governor christine
thank you very much
great to visit with you thank you
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell